whether you knew the man's direct to
work or not if you watch Doctor Who and
you like it then you owe this man a huge
debt of thanks
[Music]
so folks about a little more than a week
ago at the time that this video will go
out we have lost Terrance dicks Terrance
dicks was a British writer worked on
many things he worked on the bridge TV
show The Avengers he worked on space
1999 but for the purposes of this
channel and for most of my audience he
worked on Doctor Who
he was the script editor he held that
position longer than anybody else and
even if you don't know the name Terrance
dicks allow me to explain to you why
doctor who would not be what it is right
now without him so this is not gonna be
a full in memoriam you know rundown of
the man's entire life I'm I'm not that
good I'm not that thorough at research
and I wouldn't honestly know how to
present it so I am gonna be focusing on
his doctor who worked but obviously he
was a man who lived a full life and
worked on many things both before and
after so don't take that as the end-all
be-all Contras and they'll be our
contribution to popular culture but it
is what I'm gonna focus on today so
let's start by explaining what the
script editor even was because it's a
position that technically still exists
but what it is now at least in regards
to Doctor Who and how that show is run
is not what it was at the time he helped
position so basically the showrunner
position for Doctor Who as it exists now
that's a position that's been held by
Russell T Davies Steven Moffat and
currently Chris Chibnall that position
is basically a marriage of what had
previously been two positions during the
classic era that of the producer and the
script editor now the producer was in
charge of the show overall the script
editor actually got stuck
at the script level hounded the writers
to be sure that they were getting their
scripts in on time that their ideas were
any good massage them if needed and that
was especially important to back in the
classic era because those were all
multi-part stories so it was really
important that you had somebody to be on
top of the writers you know because if I
writers supposed to do a six part story
you really need somebody kind of you're
you're depending on them to produce not
just one good script but six good
scripts you need somebody on top of them
to make sure everything is coming
together or the way Tarun sticks himself
would put it you know I'd have people
like Terry nation tell me oh I'll have
all six scripts for you in a few weeks
and I say no Terry you're gonna give me
one script right now so I can look at it
and make sure where you're going makes
any kind of sense you're not just gonna
dump a finished story that may need
fixing on me
that was who Terence sticks wasn't
that's what he did he also did a lot of
writing of individual episodes he the
his first credited writing he did some
uncredited script work but his first
credited writing was for the wargames
the epic ten part final story for
Patrick Troughton he helped create the
master he helped create the entire idea
of the Time Lords
he wrote Tom Baker's first ever script
at first ever story robot he wrote the
first two multi doctor ones though three
doctors and the five doctors he had a
massive tangible impact on the show but
the thing that may be the most lasting
impact of anything he did was something
that I think viewers my age and younger
may not know and definitely certainly
wouldn't fully appreciate and I didn't
either until I dug a little bit more
into him that is what we're called the
Tarr
novelizations it used to be that Doctor
Who episodes would be published in the
form of novels that were basically
retelling the the serials that they were
based off of Terrance dicks wrote over
60 of those in really the the heyday of
it and eventually you know other people
came in eventually the the people who
wrote the original screenplay that they
were based off of wanted to be the ones
to write the novelizations because they
they got more money that way but the
target novelizations again if you're my
age you're younger it's hard to
understand the importance of bees
because what you need to realize is that
when Doctor Who going classic Doctor Who
was airing the 60s the 70s even into the
80s these things weren't being rerun and
in the case of the classics up they
weren't even being saved a lot of it if
you missed the original airing you
didn't see it possibly ever and home
video wasn't really a thing at all until
the 80s and wasn't affordable as a thing
most people had until late into the 80s
into the 90s so the way for a lot of
people to either get to experience the
story they didn't see because they
missed it or because it air before they
were born or if they wanted to
re-experience a cereal that they have
seen but it's not gonna air again was
the target novelizations that's what
existed instead of home video and the
reason that's important is because more
than a few prominent Doctor Who writers
of the modern era have said in
interviews and to Terrance dicks when he
was still alive
that his novelizations of those stories
were a very big part of what got them as
invested in Doctor Who as they were now
it'd be an overstatement to say that
like we wouldn't have a modern Doctor
Who at all because what imagines that if
the novelizations were lucrative they
would have happened anyways but they
were in the hands of a man who knew this
world and knew this character and knew
how to write them and was a a writer
from all indications that I can find who
didn't have a massive ego he was a
working writer he was willing to work
with whatever he was given actually one
of the eye I watched some interviews
with him one of the things he said about
coming in to be the script editor for
the Pertwee era was that he had to come
in and deal with with several massively
bad ideas the fact that the doctor was
now stuck on earth he said it was a
massively bad idea and at the time that
Pertwee started they were doing longer
serials instead of like four and six
farther they were doing like seven or
eight parters and he also said that was
a very bad idea
but he did it he made it work because
that was his mandate and he did what he
could with it Wow
currently reminding guys hey you know be
better if we didn't do this be better if
we could change this could you let me
nudge it nod it and then get it to where
he wanted it but he was a writer who
would work with what he had so he didn't
have this huge massive ego but that
meant that he would get these scripts to
adapt into novelizations and he would
recognize when what he was handed was
terrific
I again in some of the interviews I saw
he particularly cited kinda and I don't
and snake dance because he thought those
concepts were really fascinating he also
said he quite enjoyed working on scripts
for serials that weren't very good
because it gave him a chance
you help them and make them work better
you know if the effects were lousy on
the show
it'll just describe those effects he's
really good on the page and suddenly
they work so much better or if there is
a massive plot hole that snuck through
he has the chance to fix it in the
novelization but again not because he
thought I can do this better he's like
this is a better way to tell a story
that's what the guy did and you can find
quite a bit on him you can find
interviews with him and pretty much any
interview with him is going to be
primarily about Doctor Who I remember my
first impression of Terrance dicks was
and the supplementary material I believe
on the time warrior which he didn't
write but he was still the script editor
at the time and he moaning about the
inclusion of Sarah Jane he didn't like
Sarah Jane initially he didn't like the
mandate of the doctors companion having
more agency and being in a position to
kind of rescue herself at any point
because Heath he said flat out the
doctor's assistant because they were
called the assistants that back in that
era more the doctor's assistant their
job is to scream and get rescued which I
mean I'm not usually one to give a past
for you know think of the someone's age
and the time that they were brought up
but I kind of do for that and I kind of
read it kind of adorable especially
because he still worked with the
character that he was given and as a
scriptwriter he was told you know this
is what this new character is gonna be
and he may not have thought it was a
good idea but he still implemented it
and he's still made sure that it was
working for what the direction of the
show was going under the various
producers that he worked for and and
again even when he even in that little
snippet that behind-the-scenes Timbit
where he was boning Sarah chained he was
saying it with a smile he was like yeah
I didn't think this is a good idea but
what do I know it was just kind of his
his attitude and his notion and he did a
lot to steer this show
like I said he was a creative force
behind things like the Timelords the
master the entire feel of the Pertwee
era as a whole and continuing the legacy
of those stories and other ones since by
doing the target novelizations and
picking that back up again he did a
target novelization for the first set of
based off the very first story of the
Sarah Jane Adventures shows you that he
kind of got over a Sarah Jane issues he
he just kept writing and he kept coming
back to Doctor Who
he wrote a stage play which he also
didn't think was a very good idea but
he's like well okay let's see what do we
can do with it he had to do them the
last minute several last-minute changes
to to the five doctors because initially
writing it finished his first draft
thought Tom Baker was gonna be in it oh
whoops haha then figuring out how to
make that work and again not talking
about it like in again I watched a
number of interviews not talking about
it as if it was this massive thing that
he had to deal it was like I kind of
like the pressure you know going like
okay how do we fix this somebody that
gamed to just get to work I have to
admire that and he seemed to be very
proud of his time and his work on Doctor
Who and I'm gonna miss him I mean he
hasn't been an active force on the show
for some time but his influences is
gonna be felt for a long long time I
said the massive creative forces behind
the reboot the target novelization was a
big part of their formative years of
loving Doctor Who at all and it's
arguable that the show may not have
remained or at the very least some of
the earlier eras of the show may not
have remained in the public
conscience the way they did if it were
not for the novelizations if it were not
for the things that he wrote
Karen sticks you will be missed
what is your favorite story either about
Terrence dicks or that he wrote whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it whole
bunch of things to do because there are
buttons and links and you can support me
on patreon help me come from Ann bills
and hopefully one day I grow the channel
even bigger and better than it already
is
other links down there besides because
you know there's the stuff you know like
subscribe Hey
but also there's my social media links
there's my book click on things or don't
you don't have to at the end of the day
you know the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]